you're live
okay for people joining this live stream
this is a
language completeness and consistency
meeting
uh about language and our first item we
have a
assorted items our first item is about
storing search index objects and local
objects
okay so search index objects can get
quite big
and they are where are they being stored
right now
in user base directory which is what
type of thing usually what what is that
what's the name of the user base
directory is it dollar user base
directory
yes okay what is that
that says some weird what other crud is
that right now
well it's everything that's been there
you know
since 1996 or whenever we introduced
user base directory
right your password your kernel in it
your front end in it
there's also uh your wolf from alpha
cash uh
yeah entity value and an entity value
okay all the pack let's you know
right so dollar yeah so what you're
saying is there's both
there's both things that could be blown
away like all the caching stuff and all
the paclets
and those things that better not be
blown away like the index files
is that correct
and i mean whether the packless can be
blown away i mean right that's a bit of
a matter of perspective
right uh well it can be regenerated
they exist on a server your net files
are custom to you
right but the search index is more like
something that is cached right so
nowadays it should go into the other
cache based directory so
what kind of questions seem to disagree
that it's not the cash
so maybe he should speak to that point
sorry who is who is disagreeing
nicholas i believe okay in the email
thread and he's here so
he should speak for himself hi yes
i think that indices are more like
databases that you can create
manually you you insert data
you have fields you have columns and you
modify
and at some point you delete them
creating them it's an expensive
operation
and it's everything is manual
right and if you did yeah sorry i didn't
mean to interrupt but i think one thing
that we need to be clear about is that
we're not talking about like
the documentation search guys which are
sort of auto generated for you right
these are thing
we're talking exclusively about the
things you create when you call
create search index is that correct yes
i i think that if we had a system of
automatically creating indices
like uh so like opportunistically you
know
if that's the word that if you you
search for something in some path
then you automatically create an index
so that the
the next time things are faster that
would be a cache
yes i agree with that but as implemented
now
it's something you you say okay i want
to search on
these things and i create a an
index so i don't see that as
you can name the indices you create so
it's a collection of things you own and
you
you want to to manage uh so only the
anonymous ones are in user base
directory or are all of them in users
all of them but you can give them
specific names is what you're seeing yes
if you if you don't give a name you
automatically get an
uuid as a name but you can
call the indices as as one like
you know my docs okay
so give me a sense of what's in local
objects and what's
in the user base directory what's the
distinction how would we define the
distinction
i understand local objects is more like
a mechanism
it's not just a ah
a place to to to do arbitrary file
operations
right right i mean i think local objects
are
like cloud objects they're they're
things we've provided the specific
interface for
you know working with
and and they and they intend to stick
around
sure but also they're intended to be
used
by using the local objects interface
this is why i asked if the if the
suggestion was to re-implement the java
library to use local object
is because i didn't think that local
object
was a way to create a directory
that you can then do anything with which
is what the lucine library needs
what the the idea behind the local
object
is you use local object
manipulation functions to manipulate
your local
yeah objects right that that's correct i
mean if you don't need the local objects
overhead and facilities then just to
explain files directly
so it's still a local base directory
which
is that i want to compare this to which
is where the
local objects go by default but the
media can go anywhere
and in particular there is a good
use case for local objects in the cache
directory
for for cache-based stuff and but
i mean if you don't need the overhead of
local objects then just use plain files
or directory
hey does this work if i say all in the
first argument it should
okay and so what's the one for local
local object-based directory is that
right
local local base
uh well dollar local base is not a file
it's a url
so you know so you need to do file
what is it file name expand is it that
converts it
okay okay it's gonna get complicated
okay all right look i think i think this
proposal has just died
um okay i mean does anybody want to
dispute that we can go on having search
index
objects in um and user-based directory i
guess
anybody disagree no i think that's right
and just i mean roman i mean i you might
have stuck around anyway
but i think it would be useful if you
stay stuck around for the confirmed
quiet discussion certainly
and for module scope okay
okay the test returned by confirm assert
is always false right so i
it has a property called test when you
when right when the confirm assert file
fires it creates a failure object
and that has a property called test but
that
i right in that output i would have
expected to see
two greater than three or some hold of
two greater than three or something like
that not
false oh yeah go ahead
and and the same thing and basically i
think my next complaint is also about
the about the message it just says
assertion failed where i might have
expected to see
assertion two greater than three failed
and so i guess christopher you have a
reply
so please go ahead yeah so i mean the
first thing is just a
a technical thing so it doesn't actually
always return false because if it's
neither true or false then it might
return
something else because it uses true q to
determine whether it triggers but
but that so the reason for all this is
because it's not hold first
so i mean it could be hold first and
then it would be able to report things
like here was the assertion
but right now it isn't and so all it
sees is
true false or some third value oh
so i mean right i guess
it could be made hold first but it does
seem like it would be kind of it's a
purely aesthetic thing
um to do and might cause other problems
right but on the other hand it uh
yeah i mean i i don't know that it's
purely aesthetic i mean if i if i put in
an assertion right uh
right then certainly in a c assertion
right i see what assertion
fired so i don't necessarily need to go
to line
936 of file.mc i can just
see which assertion file so in this case
if
i have an assertion failure you know i
don't know what
was the assertion well maybe oh so yeah
right so well yeah so most expressions
a lot of expressions are going to
evaluate either true or false right
so that are in confirm assert
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't have been i
would have been nervous to use
something that doesn't have a definite
truth value
and confirm assert what you use is true
q
so if it returns you know if it returns
15 it will take that to mean uh
false right yeah
right but you know suppose writes it
right i mean obviously two greater than
three
is stupid right but if i if i put in you
know
input is less than zero and greater than
255
uh you know it will be useful to see
that unevaluated expression rather than
just depending on how big it gets
right right i mean i think yes
absolutely i mean i think that the only
uh right right now the only way to get
behavior like that
would be to use one of its i think it's
second argument where you can put you
know
you can put sort of arbitrary
information there and you could just put
something like
where the the assert was um as like a
human
readable string but that's that's very
manual
so
here's a question i i didn't uh i didn't
think to try because i didn't realize
it wasn't hold first what if you use
unevaluated will it
you know uh
handle that correctly
what do you mean if you have unevaluated
of two greater than three
right um i'm not sure i don't know
what what unevaluated will turn into i
think it will just evaluate because
it's not a whole first function yeah no
no no well right the whole point of
unevaluated is that it temporarily makes
the thing
hold you know hold all and until the
next thing that evaluates it
right so i mean you'd need to you'd need
to write the body of the function
correctly to avoid any evaluation leaks
but in principle that's maybe something
we could yeah but then you never know
whether it's true or false right
no no no no no you you you right
it still evaluates because the because
the code inside confirm evaluates
so i just checked you know confirm
assert unevaluated print three semicolon
to bigger than three
and it printed three exactly once which
is nice
and gave me an assertion failed right i
i'm just suggesting
i mean one thing we could do is right we
could have a whole
right i mean if the first line of the
body
is you know held you know held test
equals hold of
input then unevaluated there would
allow that two greater than three to
make it into the held expression
and maybe that's something we uh
what problem are we trying to solve here
i mean the fact that we'd like to have
better tagging i mean the truth is i
hate to say this but
since the whole confirm and close
mechanism has lexical behavior
it could actually this may be too
horrifying to even suggest
it could actually custom write its
message
lexically is that completely crazy
christopher
what do you mean it says something like
from cell blank
or from lying blank well it could it
could literally pick up this expression
as it goes through in its lexical
process of putting in tags
it could pick up that unevaluated
expression
and put it in you know hold wrappers or
whatever else it needs to do
yeah i guess i mean but there's weird
stuff about right like if you have a
width
outside of the enclosed or or for
example if you have uh
like the thing that's inside of the cert
might not be
like the thing that's most literally
lexically inside might not be very human
intelligible
i mean so another uh so so right now
just just to show how it would work
right now if you wanted to tag it
manually
you can just say enclose of confirm
assert two greater than three
and then as the second argument for to
confirm assert just say
you know foo as a string
right you get rid of the extract and
spawn though just
yeah just return the failure object
right now if you press the plus i
believe you'll see foo
right as the information so that's
that's the
closest that there is right now to to
letting you know which is cert failed
right and i suppose we don't want to
stick the information in the
in the message because it might be very
long
well maybe maybe we should actually i
mean so
in general so okay here's maybe the only
reason not to so
right now the information field which
is maybe not the best name because it
actually has like two purposes
so one purpose is exactly this it's so
that you can tag your failure objects
or so you can include any you know extra
stuff about the failure that you might
want to use later
but it's also nice because that
information field
or that argument is uh
okay actually i'm realizing there was
something incorrect from earlier but
yeah that argument is actually held
so this function i just remembered
confirmation is actually hold all
but it evaluates all of its arguments
immediately except for the information
argument
because it doesn't evaluate the
information argument until
it's actually failed so that way you can
put stuff in there like a message
um if you want to throw a message when
it uh it isn't the
best name information isn't the best
name it's kind of like
action or something but that's the wrong
name as well um
right but i mean that doesn't mean
technically it is hold all so you
could uh you could without changing its
attributes
get the some sort of held version of the
input expression so the default second
argument could be hold of first argument
yes fedex or the um i mean it comes with
a thing this this test parameter
i guess it could have another i mean
every every
every confirm every you know the failure
objects for each different confirm
has different fields so we could add a
field here for for confirm assert
that's basically the so i should call it
the assertion yeah
right and if we stuck the assertion into
the message i think that would be super
useful
right so okay so then that will be a
lexical thing that happens
that it writes the second argument or
whatever it is
or maybe it isn't the second argument i
don't know where it would store it but
it's not in the second argument it's
just there's a whole association inside
that failure object and it builds that
when the assertion fails and you can put
whatever the heck you want in it
so yeah well i think that would be nice
then if if a lexical
you know lexical preparation time
whatever it's called it tries to do this
and if if the thing that's there is
something you know
if it's a with well sorry that's the
best we can do
right i mean it's simpler than the
lexical preparation time thing though
because it's
it's just right it's just when it
evaluates to hold all function
right it just needs to be right it just
needs to store since it's an
unevaluated function it just needs to
remember to store the unevaluated input
well
made then there has to be a hold first
function to do this already hold all
right that's yeah christopher was
mistaken when he said
oh okay okay okay okay okay okay fine
then it's easy
yes then i agree and that seems like the
path forward yep okay
and there's a there's a bug number there
christopher i mean i
assigned it to you so you can you know
you can follow up
yep okay confirm quiet
so so for this one actually um i was i
was working on this bit earlier today
and i actually found a way i think to to
get around most of these
these problems um so i mean i think i
don't know who
brought this up but this is been sort of
a long going
issue because basically messages are
sort of complicated and detecting you
know if you're inside of a quiet or if
you're
there's a quiet inside of you and so on
and it's sort of a mess
but um there's this thing called um
uh so right now the behavior of
confirmed quite is kind of weird
in that um it detects
if you have a quieted if you have like
for example if i say quiet if i say
confirm quiet
of quiet of you know zero to the zero um
then the confirm quiet will trigger
so it ignores the quiet that's inside of
it which is unlike
check for example um and
as is brought up this can lead to all
sorts of weird issues
around it stephen but you know you'll
see a failure object
as opposed to the expected indeterminate
because right you quieted that message
so it shouldn't have oh i see i see i
see so confirm
quiet the the the the thing about
confirm
quiet is boy it's not obvious what you
wanted to do because
it could be the case that for cosmetic
reasons you quieted a message
but you still want to know that a
message was generated
right but then you put the quiet outside
of the confirmed quiet rather than
inside
of it which doesn't
work because quiet quiets the message so
does it yeah it does yeah oh yeah i
guess that's a true
request but yeah by the paul that's
everything but but no but so the
the only other thing though is so just
just to update on this though
so there's this thing called internal
quiet status
which i think was i went back in the old
email thread about this it was discussed
back
back then um i found actually there's
some general utilities stuff
for using quiet status to try and detect
whether or not a message has been
quieted
um and so i just was trying that earlier
today and it looks like it
it works so that may be sort of a
solution so
the behavior if you use this like this
other version i just wrote
is if you have a quiet outside of the
confirmed quiet
that does not affect it it'll just do
everything it does normally
if you have a quiet inside of the
confirmed quiet then
the confirmed quiet doesn't see the
messages which i think is
pretty much the behavior of check and
it's probably the right thing to
to do okay yeah so i i think
i certainly agree with this and i think
most other people would agree with the
proposal that confirmed quiet should
behave like czech
um the second issue and is
is sort of you'll have to bear with me
and and
and and read it so which is this this
one here
yes which right so
you know check is oblivious to general
stop because it doesn't actually
right it doesn't do anything about
quieting messages right so
one general stop will fire you know
messages after general stop are still
technically firing they're just not you
know printing anything so you see
we just see three
one of you know power in fees then a
general stop
and then we still get dollar fails
because
you know the message fired we just
didn't see any text from it in the
output
now there's a there's a slight
disagreement about sort of
confirm quiet so if you do confirm quiet
confirm quiet prevents the message from
ever being issued
which means general stop uh
never is never triggered and so you just
get five failure objects and you never
see
any messages and nothing about general
stop
i think this is okay jeremy i think i'll
let him speak for himself
i think disagrees with with this
behavior because he thinks it
contradicts the note that says confirm
quiet stops evaluation when the first ma
matching message is generated well i
well actually
my so so first of all
um i've been working with a function
like this
in the alpha code and fixing all the
bugs that keep
popping up in it because it turns out
that this function is
unimplementable so that's my first
warning is
confirm quiet is unimplementable um
without ever having bugs wait wait wait
wait wait wait but you haven't used
confirmed quiet itself
you've been using your bootleg version
of confirmed questions
this is this is something that came up
sort of this is back when we were
first talking about this like in the
summer or something
that basically there are some weird
things with messages that are actually
kind of
the the correct behavior is kind of
incoherent
and so you can just get close to it but
you cannot perfectly do it
and how does this relate to the things i
was discussing before about echo
and the possibility of being able to
have a stop for echoes
so wasn't this discussed in that meeting
there was some time we were talking
about
having these fancy echo functions and
there was going to be some outer
function that would sort of uh
there is a question like an echo pain or
something
oh that's an interesting idea that's a
good idea i i think it's a slightly
different
issue because i mean at least at the
present time just because
messages right you have on messages and
off messages and you have quiet messages
and you know you have these various
hooks that fire
in different ways depending on all this
status
right so what what's the issue here so
the issue
there might not be an issue here with
general stop
if confirm quiet is actually more than
is actually quieting the message in
addition to
terminating evaluation but right
the with the with the function that i'm
used to though you still want to see the
message it's just that you want it to
halt the evaluation
is there a way and
that's sort of my third point so suppose
we want to stop evaluation after the
first message
but we still want to see the message
which i guess is something that jeremy
wants
and it's also something that's been
requested by users over the years
so here i have something that sort of
does it but it has a couple of issues
one is
the second argument which is highlighted
in yellow is just
pretty darn complicated
and the second is that it's um
uh wouldn't you like to have a splice
that will work in more generality
uh i don't really use splice so i know
but you shouldn't use sequence at at
which is a much worse thing than splice
and whatever happened to the discussion
of splice having a second argument
gives its head anyway never mind but
we'll we'll come back to that
that's a separate ild discussion i know
i i think apply is a perfectly nice
function
so okay anyway keep going so this is
grotesque
this is a grotesque and the other thing
is rather than
giving you know i've tried to reproduce
the message but you'll notice that it's
actually
rather than giving me one over zero
which is the thing which actually
generated the message
it's giving me the whole first argument
to quiet
and so the question is can we do better
and and maybe this is just something
christopher needs to go think about
and the third problem with what you put
there is
when i open up the debugger
because i want to see where my message
fired i'm going to
see that it fired after the confirm
quiet and therefore after the actual one
over zero attempted to evaluate
instead of um at the evaluation of one
over zero
oh that that is a good point they didn't
think of about that
so i mean it's very simple for i mean
confirm
quiet right now you know it's just it
explicitly quiets
the messages that that you're detecting
because i think that is probably the
most common case is you just want to
handle the message more gracefully more
gracefully than printing messages
everywhere
but i mean it's trivial of course for it
to not quiet them
the only question is how it would do
that so i mean for example you could
imagine an option
but the problem is is that the next
argument that what is i think the third
argument for confirmed quiet
um is that that the argument currently
called information
which can be any expression and so it
can be a rule
and so you know if you wanted to have an
option
you'd have to do sort of annoying stuff
with the information i mean
that that that's that's what uh that's
what check arguments or
arguments options is for right if you if
you set the option
up if you use the para the parameter
rules mode goes or options mode goes to
shortest then it will only treat it as
an option
if it's a known option name to the head
and so so i would encourage you to
to look at those two new and 12
functions because i think they will
automate the
the processing that i agree without it
is very annoying which is why
i spent so much time on writing those
functions
yeah i mean i i i'm not i'm not very
familiar with ivan i haven't
used czech arguments and so on much yet
but um
but i mean there is a you know of course
there is a sort of genuine ambiguity
that
right now you can have anything in in
the information field and
and maybe this means you can't have a
rule that looks a certain way
where does it say that this doesn't that
this suppresses the message
yeah i don't think it does anywhere it
might in the details
it might not in which case that's a bug
but
yeah i mean it talks about does not
generate
i think it should say even here
enforces well confirms that no messages
would be generated or i see
you could say otherwise quieting them
and throwing an error blah blah
yes that's reasonable yes that's
reasonable
that should say that
and and the reason basically the the
reason to quiet them by default here
which i think is the right decision is
that you just put this in code and it's
just like if something went
wrong i want to exit here you don't want
the user to see
you know from deep in some stack of
functions some weird message about
something they don't understand
so i think that's fine but now the
question is how to unquiet
right and they i think but also
my personal opinion is an option is the
right thing and if
right it wouldn't mean you can't have
rules in general in that argument it
just means you wouldn't i couldn't have
a rule
whose left-hand side is that one option
name which i think what would be the
option
uh like re reissue message issue message
maybe or already the possibility would
be something
look here's another possibility to mess
with the second argument here
by the way what do we have what what
what possible named message groups are
there
yeah i think that's another message
groups yeah
which and it hasn't been updated for a
while so you know we probably
won't they're embarrassingly bad okay
so to me if you could do something with
that second argument
that would be a much cleaner way to deal
with it because the most common cases
you know in other words let's say
that the
second argument let's say that here
i mean i was kind of thinking if if you
could say
all or something i don't know what it is
i don't know what the right term is here
i think you can't say all i mean so that
that
that
that argument is you know painstakingly
recreates the behavior of quiet
which certainly accepts all yes
fine but but then then maybe what it
should be is something like
um um
let's say that it was expression
let's imagine maybe this is bad maybe
this is wrong
maybe this is too weird
yeah i was making more more of an
ordered pair so all
it would be list all true but that's not
going to work at all because of the fact
that you can put the
messages
well i mean i agree this is not
perfectly clean but
my inclination would be all true is just
a special case and otherwise you'd need
a list of
ordered pairs if you wanted to write the
default
of a flat list would be all off and
well but then then it's then it's very
different from quiet which is kind of
annoying
what's very different from what well
like the point is
i can so right now if i have a quiet
that says something like
you know quiet of some expression comma
and then it gives a list of five
different messages it wants to quiet
that will just work inside of confirmed
quiet but if you had to for example
annotate
every one of those messages with the
true or false then
it would look very different from the
argument you'd be too quiet
and i think that if we if we did support
if there was some sort of annotation you
could give that second argument
i think that that annotation should be
like on the outside
it shouldn't it shouldn't change
is there an obvious annotation go ahead
roman yeah my my point is that
if you use that mechanism of enclose of
confirm quiet it's kind of
up to you to decide whether you want to
issue a message or not and
issuing the original message is probably
really the thing to do
so that you mean like not quite generate
a new message
inside and close
i mean that that is an approach but i
don't think that's the approach
everybody wants
i think the approach of you see the
message but nevertheless
it exits with an exception is a
reasonable approach
which is the other case we're talking
about here right right
i mean i could imagine a special second
argument
that just generates the message like for
example inherited or some such other
thing
uh or you know something weird full
inherited whatever there that just deals
with the case
where it says oh
god that doesn't work does it
it always annoys me when there are these
arguments where there's all and there's
full and there's you know and these are
different
and then there's like subtle differences
between the five different
you know yeah well we need five new
synonyms for automatic exactly
right so hold on the maybe the way to do
it is to annotate it by having
the current payload there
and having some reason why we have blah
arrow current payload
i'm not sure what what you mean by a
payload
well i mean this thing here for example
i mean i think the case where you want
to say
oh oh well yeah so we could have it like
be either a list of rolls over an
association
where with like reissued goes to payload
and
right so you if you want all of the
right so if you only want to repeat
certain messages you say you know
re you know issued or issue or whatever
word we come up with goes to
or unquiet goes to payload quiet goes to
payload
um issued an unensued or
displayed and non dis displayed right
and those are both payloads and then the
question is what the
what the elided form so that's the very
very elaborate form
actually that's quite nice i quite like
that to put the issued messages and the
unassumed messages
right and then the the ally that form
could just be issued goes to
all i mean i think that's a perfectly
understandable and compact
yes i agree
um so if a message is issued
will it be captured by an outdoor
confirmed quiet
christopher that's for you i think i
mean
yes i think it would be right yes
and you'd want to wrap your your yeah
right unless there's an intervening
quiet
right right okay i mean this
this probably needs a little bit more
detail but i think this is the right
direction
what name do you when when would you
ever want to have
or like okay what's the situation where
you want it so that it always triggers
so the confirmed quiet you know triggers
on all this whole class of messages
but it only prints the message for some
of them
right so what's the advantage of having
something like this over just something
that
somehow indicates just true or false do
you issue all messages or none of them
it's a hack for dealing with the fact
that we want the syntactic form
of issued arrow payload
yeah i mean i i you know
so my i don't know that there's any
place
where i would really really want it but
i can certainly conceive of a pla of
a situation where you know there are
certain specific messages
i want to issue uh
you know and anything else is like you
know
an unknown error occurred and so then
those i want silent and i handled them
differently by saying an unknown error
occurred at the end
i see yeah is that a comment
is that a super robust or common
approach probably not
but i'm sure there are people out there
who write code like that and i'm not so
offended by it that i
think well yeah it's like the thing you
don't want is
that the message says unknown error
right which is just like whoever wrote
that piece of software
is crazy um
well this is this would be my my so far
from the things we've discussed that
seems to be
my preference is to do something like
this christopher does that seem
reasonable to you
yeah i mean i still think maybe an
option would be
well i don't know i i'm not particularly
happy with any of them but i guess this
is probably the best of them
i mean pla why don't we do this why
don't you play
with arguments options a bit and see how
you
you know see how you feel after you've
because i
i think with just you know 15 minutes of
work with arguments options you could
implement
implement this and then you know test it
and see how it feels and
report back to us i mean none of these
are particularly hard to implement
right but um yeah so i guess
then the question is what would the
option be called well wherever what is
there an option there's no option here
no no but in the other version where
where where it would have an option
that's something like quiet messages
true or false
no display quiet messages or something
display messages arrow true or false
well it won't necessarily display them
because there could be a quiet outside
of it oh for goodness sake
it's just it's just the question of
whether or not it will quiet the
messages
i mean if we really want to be
uh you know verbose about it
it's reissue first message
why is that first message oh i see
because it stops
oh gosh
that's a good point
i think this requires more thought i
mean i would suggest that christopher
thinks about this case
and the possible uh you know i i prefer
this case
i think nobody's ever going to use an
option here i think they're just going
to write their code differently
whereas here i can imagine somebody just
flipping
you know putting in issuedero inside a
piece of otherwise
you know
reasonable right and and and the default
presumably will be non-issued
correct non-issue goes to all
right right it's the effect of default
uh question in the message group
business are we ever going to do
anything with that is that
some you know whoever maintains wall
from language data
that's probably or i don't know who who
maintains the message documentation
there isn't a whole lot of message
documentation yeah i guess there was i
mean dave whitoff wrote a whole
big giant messages book at some point
for specific messages yes
uh well the the so the situation is
i you know oliver and i who are
probably the two people who write the
most message pages complain about
how hard it is to do in docutools and
brian v is like well you know you guys
are the only ones
you know the the this tab isn't used
very much so we don't spend much time
maintaining it and so
the short answer is there's nobody
overall in charge
and you know those of us who try to
update those
find it difficult because the tooling is
not super robust although maybe maybe
he's given it a little bit of love but
it's still not super easy well i mean
that that whole tooling
for special case pages should get a lot
better as they become form notebooks
but my question is
look this really is pretty lame and i
think this is useful because i mean i
think
confirmed quiet is a good way to catch i
mean the thing i've been pushing for for
ages is these messages are off by
default
is there a known performance hit of
having messages that are off by default
i don't know there shouldn't be if there
is it's bad
my guess is that there is some i mean
like for example if you had a message
that was off by default that was you
know
every time you did addition then i think
that would
kill you yeah well that's the thing we
need to look at
i i still think i mean this
this whole mechanism is still fairly
young of
you know the confirming close mechanism
i think it's probably starting to get
more widely used
but i i still think this will be very
useful
but maybe it's undoable i mean maybe
it's just you know it's like
like the question of verbosity levels
right and i mean the other question is
first of all what's a use case where
you're actually going to pick a message
group
and two what message groups would there
be because
it seems to me like most of the cases
are there's either a specific message
there's
one thing that can go wrong that you
want to catch like one over zero
or you just want to catch everything you
know
and you're no i'll tell you the ones
that i'm look the
class that i would think are the things
somehow
stayed symbolic and shouldn't have done
okay so so basically i mean right and
there's a whole massive class of
messages that go with that
yeah i mean it's like it's it's right
i mean look also also i might want to
just
quiet all messages from
gaussian matrix and there's no sin
and i don't know off the top of my head
what all those messages could be
and um so i want to do
gaussian matrix colon colon star but
that's not
a valid syntax right and you can't do
a message name of uh gaussian matrix
comma blank or something like that
either
so right i mean that's something where i
mean i think it might be
good to maybe support some stuff like
that you know both in this end and quiet
yeah i agree i mean that's certainly
something that has been requested um
look the main point is what are the
scenarios
and we're not going to get this in this
meeting we should have a separate
discussion at some other time
the scenarios message cascade scenarios
one is something stayed symbolic and
shouldn't have done
that generates a message cascade you
know in a
okay one question that relates to this
next item is
you know if we were a typed language all
the way down
certain things would error out that do
not for us
but hey that's that's not it's not the
message cascade it's it's the crappy
evaluation cascade that's happening
that's causing the message
right i was gonna say so a few errors
caused
like fatal things that through
exceptions that went up to top level
then you wouldn't get the evaluation
casca that's the whole point of the
confirm
that's the whole point of confirm is
that you're not
i mean that's what we're dealing with
here is we okay so your point is
what i'm saying is at the initiation of
a symbolic cascade so to speak
if we can nip it in the bud with a
confirmed quiet or something
then we're done then we're not going to
get any evaluation cascade
because it's going to have been you know
unconfirmed so to speak
yep and so maybe maybe the point is that
you want
one set of message groups to just be
um the various arg acts and
option value type of things that get
issued when a function is evaluating its
arguments
but of course there are many other
reasons why functions might return
unevaluated right but my claim is
the generic thing you want is and now
actually
at this point about nipping it in the
bud i think is the important point
as soon as something you know if you rap
or confirm something or other around a
thing
to say okay if this returned unevaluated
it's wrong
i mean the best thing would be that you
can wrap a confirm
something around a small block of code
and have it be the case that if
something inside there
returned unevaluated and started
cascading because the disadvantage
tom is that unless you write confirm
quiet around every single function
you can't nip it completely in the bud
the thing is
that's the whole no no unfortunately
that's that's a flaw in the whole the
whole the whole thing
when i write code if there's a failure i
want it to
exit immediately i want it to core dump
you know because
i will go and fix it if if i don't do
that then none of the code could
possibly
you know would ever get that's a
suggestion of a confirm
that looks inside and infects everything
go ahead
because well no no maybe confirm so
you're right so none of the confirms
look inside except for confirm quiet
because if a message happens anywhere
inside the confirmed quiet matter how
deep it is
and or how no matter how you know
dynamically scoped etc it is
it's going to it's going to stop so i
mean if you did have things like
messages that were you know if it was
detecting the messages that got thrown
when you know
things return evaluated then right which
is why i keep on
pushing for this idea of messages that
may even be off by default
that just say this evaluated
symbolically
well maybe there's also just a wave i
mean some way of standardizing
all of those uh well
i don't know i guess the thing you could
do is
things that have down values that
you know evaluates right right we would
consider this i mean this is
so though in the early days there was
discussion of what was it confirm
evaluated or firm evaluates or something
like this
and and basically it was it was sort of
there were all sorts of issues
because uh you know there were things
about you know you
things with value queue didn't quite
work and then and then also there was
the idea of
just checking if the expression changed
but then there's stuff where uh you know
the the
square root for example doesn't evaluate
but yet it's undoubtedly a perfectly
valid thing
right anyway this is i think a separate
discussion
let's just have a quick look at the
other things on this agenda
that we need to wrap up my question here
confirm
types or type checked or something we
since we've got a whole type calculus
now
why not have something where you can
give it an expression and give it the
type that's expression supposed to have
and it can determine whether it does
have that type
how do you tell given a type
specification whether an expression
matches that type
well i'm not sure that expressions have
types i mean the expressions
maybe are castable to certain types but
an expression just has type expression
right i mean so right so certainly in
the compiler right it says
if the inputs have this type then you
can
prove that these resulting expressions
have
certain types it's not like at
uh an expression on its own has a type
well you could treat you could turn an
expression you could pull out free what
looked like free variables
and give them types turn it into a
function right have to turn an
expression into a function
yeah that's not what i had in mind i
mean the main thing i had in mind is
how do we simulate i mean the thing
people like about typed languages is the
thing you were saying earlier tom
which is this thing wasn't didn't wasn't
the right shape
called yeah yeah right and so i want to
know
given that we now have type annotations
you know if we sprinkled type
annotations in code
and then essentially forced our analog
of a core dump when the type annotations
don't match
could we do that you want to do that
with inferencing not not off
run you want if it doesn't meet a type
you want to
that's what i'm saying yes right well
that's so what you want to know then
is given an expression is it an instance
of a type
that's what i want to know exactly so
that's now
a lot of these types are quite like some
of our
you know sort of you know quantifier
type of syntax so do we not have
instance of or well we might have that's
what i'm asking for yeah that's right
that's right i mean we talked about the
things like that it's perfectly well
defined
so right sure but we we talked about
this a bit in the compiler
meeting i think a little bit ago and
i think the question is so first of all
is it not the case that sort of the top
level equivalent of
of types like this should just be
patterns and then this is just confirmed
match
and alternatively i mean maybe this is a
bit of what what tom is going to be
saying
you know if we had a function that was
sort of a topical function where you'd
say
is this expression an instance of or
maybe castable to an instance
of this type then you could use confirm
buy
and and also get a similar result
right i mean the thing you're given is
an expression so you would be
casting the expression to the type and
if that succeeds then
you're happy and if it doesn't you're
not right but i mean
it just seems like i i don't know if
anyone disagrees with this i mean
it seems like patterns are the more
standard
probably more concise cleaner way
of representing basically the same idea
i know but we've
got a whole right but we've got a whole
my point is
you know like integer 16 or something
you know it would be of interest to know
whether the thing you have the
expression you have
can be cast to an integer 16.
i i i i agree with you perhaps i mean
i think that's a pretty niche taste
though i mean i i think
so i i think that it might there might
be some cases where you want to know
that
particularly if you're about to pass
this integer to some compiled code
but then i think that the it's it's a
niche enough thing
that i think it shouldn't have its own
function and instead you should just use
confirm buy
with a sufficiently nice uh fair enough
curry
that might be true right all i'm
suggesting then is that the
um you know the the type dynamic type
checking
of castability should be a thing and
maybe this should be in the compiler
meeting
and we are running out of time here but
i did want to just
i did want to just mention module scope
okay so i've seen people trying to use
module scope what the heck
okay this is okay do people know what
module scope is
no is this the general utilities thing
it is
it's a thing that allows you to
not to basically say
lexically within this module let's see
can i load it
no no so it's it's all it does is it
just
it looks lexically it uses cases and it
finds all the
instances of set and set delayed and
then it puts them into a module
so basically it's a module but where you
don't have to declare the variables
okay so people like max use it all the
time and i have to rip it out of his
code
but you you don't have to give any i
mean
another thing you could do is you you
give some markup on the symbol like
variable i but that could appear
anywhere
you know there's another solution which
i think is a better solution it should
just be part of code assistance
as soon as you type module right you can
just type module
like this and then as soon as i type x
equals six
it would it would give you a thing that
says put that in the module
yeah i mean the the the the the uh
the uh wolf workbench
has had this feature for more than a
decade
so i i i agree i i 100
that is something i use all the time and
because i declare
i can see oh is this a variable i meant
to introduce or is that a typo i need to
fix
but i can tell by the coloring so i
agree
i agree 100 with an easy way to add it
to the module via code assistance is
good
but just auto scoping is just a recipe
for subtle bugs
fine okay all right so can we feed this
to brenton please
yeah sure code assistance and we might
even want to
i mean i'm wondering whether the color
whether even syntax coloring whether
these could be slightly
lighter blue for example if you
explicitly type
in a module you type a variable like
this
that well i think the more common
instance like i i think
right if you put the x in there you'll
get a diff right it'll be colored as a
local variable right so you can
tell the difference fair enough right
but i think that the more common
instance and there probably isn't much
helping this
but um the case where i miss module
variables is if i've written something
outside of module
and i've defined a bunch of variables
globally while i was
writing it and then i copied into module
and everything is black
and and so i i forget to add a variable
but i don't think there's really much
helping that because it's not like
you're going to
you know highlight every single
user-defined symbol in
in blue or something like that the
minute you copied into a module
right that that although again that's
something where code assistance like we
you could have a look for or add all
left-hand sides or something right yes
but we should we should
deal with that encode assistance okay
let's just see if we can deal with this
yeah the conditional expression i think
we can deal with with
with what the heck is the difference
between these
it's the the the styling of df maybe
it's not coming through
billy should be here and maybe also
jeremy
um i'm fine with this number three
okay that looks fine to me so billy just
give me the spec i mean this roots thing
is probably a bigger conversation that
we should
so if you really have to go yeah i have
to go so
i i would just invite you on the very
first differential route object
in there uh so at the top sorry
at the uh the start of the section that
no no right there the the y prime the y
of 12.
if you just click on it
right what are you telling me that it's
useless well i'm telling you
that i'm just telling you the the you
know
why these are why we
why it was obvious that these shouldn't
have just tool tips because
yes i i've never thought they should
have tool tips i'm i don't think the
tool tip is a good idea i think this
should unhover
it should light up you should click it
you should get a pain the pain should
have all kinds of interesting things in
it
all right well we'll have more time next
meeting to this
we'll start with this and also the
updates to the output size limiter
and things like that so sounds good all
right
good stuff thanks guys